I was thinking a lot about America it
seems like a lot of people these days
and a lot of like article writers and
stuff they're like America needs
diversity and American exists and look
America is quickly becoming extremely
more diverse than it was when I was a
kid and that will not change and that's
great that's the direction America is
headed right I was talking to some
friends of mine who were from China I'm
like is it weird sometimes that we
it's almost like we're trying to change
America
it's like oh people are moving here from
um Guam then we need to make America
more like Guam so they feel comfortable
but that's not the truth
for me it isn't for me it feels like and
I'm happy to be wrong that
um that America wants to be this thing
you know it wants to be this wild Fancy
Cat you know a cat that also sometimes
wears a raccoon for a coat you're like
dang is that cat wearing oh yes it
is
you know and so
um and so people don't they don't want
you to to kill the wreck to kill the cat
in the raccoon coat they don't want you
to change you know people
they don't want to come from Guam and be
like oh good this is just like Guam
they want to be accepted but we don't
have to make America a different place
to fit everybody
that's not a country that's an
airport
you know that's a gas station you know
we want to have something for everybody
well we do want to have something for
everybody
and that's acceptance but I think we can
also still have this thing that America
is
and yes some of the things that America
is are dumb some of them are awesome
but that's just like everywhere else
dude
bro some there's one country
um China somebody my buddies tell me you
can eat dick over there you could buy a
couple of little sack of dicks
dude
what
now there are there big articles in
China saying we gotta you know people
you know no more dicks people want
salmon when they come here no
because it's China you go there to get
you know when you're there you want it
to be what it is
and and it's like I don't think we
should sacrifice whatever America is
you know the good like as if that's bad
for us
you know as if like oh it's the same old
uh apple pie and cheddar cheese and
um you know and and people who's you
know and drinking Mountain Dew
so what
then that's what it is man
things will evolve but at the same time
like
you know we can't turn America it's not
Epcot Center I think it can still be
America
and people can come to America and they
can be oh this is cool this is America I
might not be originally American but I
live here
so sometimes I feel like there's just
this is there's this unhappiness out
there where people are like we have to
change everything has to change
ah man
the only thing that slowly will is
changing over time
and and for some people it's quicker is
our hearts and our ability to accept
each other
you know and sometimes that takes a
long time dude
you know it takes a long time some
places don't have a lot of diversity
doesn't make them a bad place
but it's going to be unique to them
you can't force overnight it's like
this
you know it's like sign this paper that
says you're not you know you've never
had a racist thought
why can't it be crazy to sign that
I don't think anybody's no I don't think
anybody in the world could sign that
you know but just because you have
thoughts or you have questions it's like
we can't just get caged up people forget
this about America what we have has
been heavily defended
heavily defended we've had a lot of Wars
in four or 500 years
1492 I guess I don't know and is that
even real who knows
you know there's been a lot of lives of
going through this
to uphold this country people forget
about all that
you know and people are like well you
know they took the land from the Indians
yeah well they did man what the
they were fighting over it
yeah it was up but that's what
happened a lot of up a lot
of happened over the years
the dinosaurs
they they broke a lot of ice and stuff
walking on ice
whose fault are they climate haters
are they ice killers
who knows
you know it was a different time it was
Cutthroat and they could get back to
that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one